some of the expectations are that as
soon as you strap some some glasses on
this will be instantly connected to the
world around you and everything will be
in context you won't have to consult
Google ever again it will just bring up
content and I don't think that's a
realistic expectation at the moment
we're very much in the infancy in terms
of wearable technologies and the
hardware is not here yet
wearables in conjunction with like
sensors and biometric so think of the
Apple watch in the way that that's
interacting with your biometric readings
that may determine dynamically how you
view something a visualization may be if
you're looking at an anatomical diagram
you may use your own haptic feedback
your heartbeat and that may change the
anatomical heart that you see in front
of you in terms of of the heartbeat and
regulating it what's the reality of
what's actually able to do for us I
think in the short-term not much that we
couldn't do already apart from not
allowing you to take out your smartphone
and very quickly notifying what's
happening whether you received an email
or a text message I don't see it kind of
overtaking traditional devices or
smartphone technology I think it's just
another kind of auxilary device that you
can gain insight into your latest the
email or what the weather's like I don't
see any long-term prospects in terms of
the technology and the hardware as it
stands now a knack of finding a use case
that you didn't even know existed yet
they do have an act of cutting the
carbon a niche in that respect do you
think that's possible or do you think
literally the the size or power of
something that size is going to limit it
yeah I think the size of the screen and
the way that you can interact with
anything that appears on the screen will
be a limitation in terms of take-up if
you think of a tablet we can pretty much
replicate what we do on a laptop or a
desktop device quite easily but if you
take that down to a smartphone it
becomes more difficult to a watch almost
impractical so in terms of automatic
dynamic in form a
in terms of biometric readings you might
substitute it for kind of a fitness band
so you might want more user focused
personal information that you might want
to collect using that method but in
terms of a way of using your everyday
functionality like email surfing the web
I don't think just because you can talk
into it is a unique selling point I
would never kind of see a person wearing
wearables for 24 hours a day it will be
for a specific task like maintenance
likes and bringing up information in
context for their environments it would
never be always on always connected type
of thing unless they were in an
environment say like a an archeological
dig where they were taking readings all
the time and they needed that visual
help and support so one of the issues I
think with Google glass is that it
didn't really have a unique selling
point it didn't really have a target
what what was the purpose of the device
in the first place and I think that was
one of its shortfalls what was that
quote from Jurassic Park that just
because you can it doesn't mean you
should so yes and I think there are
other wearables on the market that are
being used in industry that perhaps
aren't as trendy and haven't
proliferated the mainstream market but
are being actively used for a purpose
probably those those were the main issue
is the worked in navigation with Google
glass you still have to bring your hand
up to the device and swipe so it wasn't
a truly hands-free environment there are
various ways around this audio kind of
instructions using your head as it as a
mouse I guess to track the environment
and then clicking on on the wearable to
activate something in the real world but
I think the long-term solution is that
wearables should be used with the
environment so there shouldn't be in a
intermediary device that you have to
click
can connect with it should just be the
user clicking on areas of the
environment and the information
automatically being displayed to them
the other issue is AR space who owns the
space around you a couple of years ago
there was I think Starbucks or coaster
in the UK were developing an AR
location-based app through wicket ood
which is Wikipedia's AR kind of solution
and someone over a piece of AR
location-based data had put a Starbucks
branding sign
so obviously this issue to do with AR
space and who owns it will become a lot
more prevalent in the future because in
terms of legal ramifications if you were
slandering an company or a person would
work within that country and you could
have that information on the internet
how is that different to writing
something on in a blog on the internet
that it's inflammatory suppose a coffee
company could register a rivals brand
within the AR base to basically plaster
their logo over something else alone yes
so it's like guerrilla marketing I
suppose yeah anytime the word coffee
comes up somewhere it recognizes it puts
a hyperlink to the nearest are boxes
yeah and that way a lot of the users
experience will be personalized in the
same way that we have act ads dictated
to our kind of web surfing behavior how
could you decide the AR spec sure it
depends on the app you use at the moment
it is app specific so it all is all
served with an app but the way I see it
kind of translating in the future is
that it should be as transparent as as
possible and say it will be built into
an end device without you having to go
into an app so you'd open up the camera
and it would have a our information in
front of you may be served by your
previous history within interacting with
other apps and that sort of thing so
we're not quite at Minority Report
but we're getting there slowly the other
area that I'm quite interested in where
it could have a tangible benefit is a
lot of billions of pounds worth of money
in the UK is been plowed into BIM which
is Building Information modeling so
information about energy efficiency
about the way that the buildings wired
air conditioning units that sort of
information but if you think about it
being used with emergency services on
heads-up displays in the future of that
information those big data sets could be
visualized in smoke-filled environments
to allow the the nearest access to an
emergency exit or a fire hydrant
that may not be that obvious to someone
that goes into those environments so it
could potentially save lives
so I'm now actually seeing a real yes
with the operating system on there
scientists or researchers would submit
jobs the job scheduler which get run on
one of these and/or exclusive or not
there's rather better drawn and neater
gates only three of them make pixels are
doing green and three of them a diffuse
it does so different camera
manufacturers may have different ways of
doing this